you're seeing a strange
leaning into a kind of conservatism
coming from pop music
you're seeing it come from
someone named billy eilish
now i'm no expert on billy eilish okay
i've never listened to a billy eilish
tune
i wouldn't really be able to pick her
out of a lineup
but billy eilish
has just come out
and uh and made a very conservative
point she
she's come out against porn as a woman
i think porn is a disgrace and i
used to
watch a lot of porn to be honest i
started watching porn when i was like
11.
wow and
um
you know it's
i i didn't understand why it was a a bad
thing i thought i thought that's how you
learned how to have sex and i used to be
like the person that would like talk
about porn all the time i'd be like oh
so stupid that anybody would think that
porn is bad or [ __ ] up or you know i
think it's so cool and it's great and
it's and it's what kind of porn were you
watching i was an advocate and i
you know thought i was one of the guys
and would talk about it and think it was
really cool for for for not having a
problem with it and not seeing why it
was
bad and you know i uh
i think it really destroyed my brain and
um i feel
incredibly
devastated that i was exposed to so much
porn
am i listening to the howard stern show
or the mailbag
on this show where a lot of young people
mostly men but occasionally sometimes
women write in and make the same exact
point that billy eilish is making
established titles is your opportunity
to earn the title of lord or lady in
scotland just like me
your humble host lord michael knowles
all you need is a one square foot plot
of land and a certificate established
titles is a project based on an historic
scottish custom where landowners are
referred to as lards
or lords and ladies in english in your
title pack you will receive at least one
square foot of dedicated land on a
private estate and an official
certificate with a crest your
certificate will include a unique plot
number with which you can see the exact
location of your land you can even get a
couple pack for you and your spouse or
loved one of unspecified distinction you
will be able to have land right next to
one another at one square foot and you
will both get to be called lord and lady
you can get this on your credit card on
your plane tickets you can even put it
on your dating profiles
established titles currently having a
massive holiday sale on top of that sale
you can get an additional 10 off any
purchase you make with discount code
knowles so click the link below or go to
establishtitles.com knowles use promo
code noles to save an extra 10
today
right wing retrograde
activist um
billy eilish is coming out against porn
is she no she's not she's not
a bible thumper
or
reactionary or retrograde or any of
these things she's
about as pop mainstream
lib as it gets and she's saying that she
feels that that porn destroyed her brain
because she like so many people who are
in gen z and millennials to a lesser
degree millennials were exposed to porn
at a pretty early age too but
uh less so than than gen z where
basically they're just saturated in it
from the moment they're born
she she says that being exposed to this
at a young age and getting addicted to
it is destroying her brain people right
into my mailbag all the time
as you have heard on this topic
and they say i know that i'm supposed to
be cool and hip and we're all supposed
to be fine with porn and actually pro
porn but i think it's bad and maybe
we've got to do something about this
problem they're recognizing this because
it is true
and
they're recognizing that while the way
that the porn industry and the sexual
revolutionaries sold porn is that it's a
way to increase your freedom don't let
the those old constraints and those old
nasty preacher men tell you what to do
man you know just just enjoy your
freedom to watch women be degraded
that's how it was sold and virtually
everybody in the culture
at some point has given into this
temptation or even believed that lie
outright
but it turns out it's not true it
doesn't make you free it actually
enslaves you it gets you addicted to
things and it warps your brain and billy
eilish was talking about how she got
really addicted to this particularly
violent kind of porn and it messed up
her relationships and it actually does
change your brain chemistry so there are
actually physical effects of this as
well and obviously extremely corrosive
psychological and spiritual effects
and it seems to me the only people who
don't get it
are the squishy right wingers the
hard left understands what this stuff
does porn and drugs and this culture of
licentiousness they know what it does
and they are wielding it actively
wielding it to compromise your freedom
and change the culture they write about
this i actually write about them writing
about this in my book speechless which
makes a great christmas present by the
way number one national bestseller great
gift to give to your friends or family
so the hard left notes about this the
conservatives the actual conservatives
know that
but it's just the sometimes they're
called the lbertarians you know the very
unserious squishy just you do you types
who who kind of fall on the right they
seem to be the only ones who don't get
it
that this is a really powerful thing
and when you legalize all porn just like
if you legalize all drugs just if you
legalize all manner of licentiousness
advice that's not going to free you it's
going to enslave you and it's going to
enslave you to bad dudes on the left
billy eilish gets it you should too
i'm so glad you liked that clip now
if you want to get all the clips and all
the shows and all the episodes you've
got to
ring the bell and subscribe that way
you'll get notifications and by the way
if you really want to guarantee you get
notifications for the whole show head on
over to apple podcast spotify stitch or
google play wherever you get your audio
podcast subscribe
maybe leave a five star review if you
like it we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]